no one is applying 60 peas and rubbing
their hands together and patting it in
I don't think I'm even exaggerating when I
say clean beauty is literally killing people
here is a little known fact about mineral
sunscreens a lot of them actually contain
unregulated chemical sunscreens which isn't
always a big problem but it also kind of is
I'm Michelle chemistry PhD cosmetic chemist
and massive sunscreen nerd and today we're
talking about inactive ingredients in
sunscreens that aren't really inactive
it's not that easy to make a sunscreen it
might seem like all that's important in a
sunscreen are the active ingredients
after all they're listed separately
on a label in the US and Australia
and the percentages are right there
but if you just mix these ingredients
into a base you probably won't get SPF 50
that's because how these are distributed
in the rest of the sunscreen is really
important to how well the sunscreen
blocks UV that's why sunscreen is one
of the most difficult products to
formulate lots of things like the
other ingredients and how they're mixed
together can make a really big difference
it's one of the reasons why it can be hard
to predict the SPF of the sunscreen just from
the active ingredient percentages which I've
talked about before in my video on SPF testing
one cosmetic chemist told me it took
her six months to update an existing
SPF 30 sunscreen to make it up to SPF 50 as
well as changing the levels of the active
ingredients she also had to change a whole
bunch of the inactive ingredients as well
and that's just to update a sunscreen making a
sunscreen from scratch would take even longer
so there are a bunch of inactive
ingredients out there that can
help the actives in the sunscreen
work better to get you a higher SPF
these are commonly called SPF boosters a lot
of these really are just helping out the proper
sunscreen actives some are film formers and
solvents that help keep the sunscreen actives
spread out in an even film on your skin it's a
bit like a smooth paint versus one that isn't
mixed up well if the coverage isn't even
you end up with gaps in the paint layer
so analogy time it's like a football
team spreading out in front of the goalie
some boosters change the way the UV travels
in the sunscreen film for example there are
particles that bounce the UV around for longer in
the sunscreen film so it has more of a chance to
get absorbed so I guess this is like your football
players getting better at deflecting the ball
but some of them actually function just
like chemical sunscreens they absorb UV
light and convert it to other forms of energy
like heat exactly like a chemical sunscreen
so this is just like dumping a
whole bunch of extra players onto
your field which is illegal in football I think
take butyloctyl salicylate it's
usually branded as a solvent or an
emollient moisturizer and it does do these
things but it does a lot more than that
here is its structure and here
is the structure of octisalate
the official name for octisalate is ethylhexyl
salicylate which as you can tell from the name is
butyloctyl salicylate's relative but is it a twin
brother or a distant cousin three times removed?
well the first part of the name tells you how
many carbon atoms are attached to this right
part of the structure there are four
more carbons in butyloctyl salicylate
if you know a bit of chemistry or if you've
watched my video on how sunscreens work you'll
know that the section that absorbs UV is not
the bit that's different it's this salicylate
part on the left hand side with the ring that
absorbs the UV light and it's identical in
both molecules the bit that's different
doesn't actually interact with UV at all
this is what the absorbance spectra look like
they both protect against UV around the same
so butyloctyl salicylate is really just
octisalate's identical twin brother with
slightly longer hair functionally
and in every other relevant way
really they are the same thing they
both protect against UV around the
same and octisalate can also act as
a solvent and moisturizing emollient
so why isn't butyloctyl salicylate
classified as a proper sunscreen
active ingredient and put in that
top box with the percentage shown
well it seems like the manufacturer just decided
not to go through the proper legal process
sunscreen actives in most regions
are regulated in a special way this
includes in the EU where sunscreens
are technically cosmetics but approved
sunscreen actives are included in
a special list in the regulations
getting a chemical sunscreen ingredient or any
sunscreen active registered means you have to go
through a special process this involves submitting
a whole bunch of safety data for regulators to
assess and based on that they decide if it's
going to be approved if there are any special
conditions of use so for example if it could
be used in sprays or lip balms if it needs a
warning label if there's special grades allowed
and what the maximum percentage allowed should be
getting the safety data as well as
the whole process of registration
can be very expensive and it takes many years
if you look at the reports for MCE or Mexoryl
400 which was officially approved in the EU
in 2020 some of their safety data that
they submitted is almost 10 years old
now maybe you might be thinking all this admin
seems kind of unnecessary why is there all
this red tape well these processes are in
place for a reason to ensure that everyone
stays safe if you buy a random sunscreen
from a store and use it you want to be
reasonably confident that you won't massively
poison yourself or get sunburned using it
before drug regulation became a thing in the
early 1900s people would get really sick or
even die from taking medications you'd
have medicines with opium and alcohol
in them even baby medicines which I guess at
least would make people feel better for a bit
this is the whole reason that
pretty much every country has
some sort of drug regulation and within
the regulations of the regions that I
looked at if you're using an ingredient
in a sunscreen to absorb UV and protect
the skin from that UV you are meant to
register it so from a legal perspective
butyloctyl salicylate probably should have
been registered as a proper sunscreen active
so why hasn't anyone done anything
about this I honestly don't know in
Germany and Switzerland it's been pointed out as a
problem before by government agencies
but then nothing actually happened
so is this a problem using it is really
widespread and accepted in industry tons
of brands have it in their sunscreens from
multinational brands down to really small
brands who probably don't even
realise it's in their products
I think that's because butyloctyl salicylate
is probably quite safe most of the time
octisalate is generally considered one
of the safest sunscreen ingredients and
given how similar this is you would expect
the safety profile to be pretty similar
in most places you're allowed up to five
or ten percent octisalate I didn't see any
justification for how they came up with this but
octisalate hasn't been officially flagged since
butyloctyl salicylate is recommended at
two to ten percent so it seems like most
of the time the total amount of these
two combined probably stays under 10%
so to me it seems like it's probably not
a huge issue for us as sunscreen users
for people allergic to salicylates it might be an
issue if they don't check the inactive ingredients
but more of an issue is the lack of a dose limit
because it isn't regulated butyloctyl salicylate
is probably safe at a similar dose to octisalate
but I suspect that some of these mineral
sunscreens that are using really small amounts
of zinc oxide and titanium dioxide might be using
a fair shake more butyloctyl salicylate than is
recommended and that could potentially be unsafe
but it is hard to tell just from the ingredients
list how much is being used and whether the
formulators are being responsible and that is just
one of the risks of not having proper approval
but what I do have a massive gripe with
is brands that put butyloctyl salicylate
in their 100% mineral sunscreens while
bashing chemical sunscreens butyloctyl
salicylate is basically just octisalate
but less safe because it doesn't have these
extra safety precautions that come with
a properly approved sunscreen ingredient
like having performed safety studies having
a regulator go through the safety studies
to work out the conditions for using it safely
having a limit on how much you can put into a
product having to declare the percentage
having assays done to check batches of
raw materials coming in and whether they're
stable in the final formula and I could go on
and all of this really highlights a common
problem with clean beauty called regrettable
substitution they demonise particular
ingredients for being toxic based on
misinformation and misinterpretation
of studies which I have talked about
before but these ingredients were used in
products for a reason they have a function
it is really difficult maybe even impossible to
formulate a 100% mineral sunscreen that gives
high SPF while also being nice in texture
and not sticky no white cast not drying
so now that the clean brands have scared
potential customers about chemical sunscreens
they can't use them and sunscreens are
one of the few products where there is
a very clear indication of how well it
works right on the label the SPF number
so these brands are profiting off the
fear they've promoted about chemical
sunscreens while sneakily or maybe even
unknowingly using a less safe ingredient
when they really could have just been
transparently using octisalate instead
and I'm sure a lot of clean beauty brands
have no idea about this because you kind of
have to be a bit clueless about science to
be a clean beauty brand in the first place
I mean if you look at these ingredients in the
environmental working groups database in their
in my opinion typical pseudoscientific way
they've rated octisalate as higher hazard
than butyloctyl salicylate I'm assuming
it's just because octisalate is actually
an approved chemical sunscreen that's had
more safety studies done or perhaps maybe
it's because they wanted to be able to
give more brands their ewg verified label
which has an application fee of $500 and then a
tiered fee structure based on profits of course
I actually didn't realize how big
a problem this was until recently
as a lot of you probably know from
my repeated complaints I do not like
mineral sunscreens so I never really paid
too much attention to their marketing I
think they're unnecessary for most people
a lot of people are only suffering through
them and probably getting less sun protection
because of this clean beauty misinformation
and now that I've looked into
the marketing it turns out that
a lot of clean 100% mineral chemical-free
sunscreens were functionally combination or
hybrid sunscreens containing mineral
and chemical sunscreens all along
and now we have come to the part of the video
where we take a little scenic tour through what
is in my opinion clean beauty hypocrisy
all of the following is purely my opinion
let's start with colorescience they have
inactive butyloctyl salicylate high up in the
ingredients list for pretty much all of their
non-tinted sunscreens they say 100% chemical
free active ingredient a lot of sunscreen
brands that use butyloctyl salicylate say
this I'm letting most of them off the hook
if they don't have any other stuff trashing
chemical sunscreens even though these EU marketing
guidelines do say all free-from claims without a
good reason are unfairly fearmongering on
their own plus since butyloctyl salicylate
is acting as a chemical sunscreen it
should also count as a dishonest claim
let's skip past the fact
that zinc oxide is a chemical
they say colorescience has never and will
never use any chemical sunscreen actives I
guess maybe they should put legally approved
in there colorescience actually highlight the
reasons they don't use chemical sunscreens
and they mention octisalate specifically
a bunch of times they say you're not
meant to use it when you're pregnant
and to use their product that
has outlaw octisalate in it
to me mentioning pregnancy is just particularly
predatory because when you're pregnant you are
super anxious there are so many rules and
conflicting info about what you can and
can't do and there's all these hormones going
through your body so this to me is pretty gross
they say octisalate is a penetration enhancer
I think this comes from studies that look
specifically at penetration of small molecules
like herbicides and hormones not sunscreens other
studies have also found that regular moisturisers
do it too but again they are using an ingredient
that is so much like octisalate in their product
that it almost definitely does the same thing
a whole bunch of these zinc sunscreen
brands have also started saying that
the FDA is asking for additional safety
data on chemical sunscreens which is true
but in a lot of other regions regulators have
checked the safety data for the same chemical
sunscreens and approved them it's mostly
that the FDA is very slow with sunscreen
reform and has specific requirements for
for the new tests that they want and for
butyloctyl salicylate there is no safety data
required by the FDA because it's ducking the
regulations and it hasn't been checked to
the same extent in any other country either
if you're saying chemical sunscreens
are so dangerous then your ingredient
is worse so maybe you shouldn't be
exaggerating how dangerous they are
now most brands mentioning this FDA stuff are
talking about chemical sunscreens in general
but what's super interesting to me is that
colorescience says the FDA wants extra data
on 11 ingredients they list them here there's no
octisalate but if you go to the FDA page that they
link it actually says the FDA wants extra info
on 12 ingredients this particular page doesn't
have the 12 listed but in every other list from
the FDA octisalate is right there so to me this
really does seem like they realise that their
ingredient is basically octisalate in a wig
these names are difficult to pronounce I really
don't think they can argue that octisalate is
harder to pronounce than butyloctyl
salicylate like I am struggling with
that word and colorescience is already
really hard to pronounce like I don't
even know if I'm saying that correctly I
think it's correct but I have been saying
colorescience and I've heard that
everywhere a whole bunch of times
harmful chemicals entering the bloodstream
spreading across the body causing harm
disrupting the endocrine system affecting
hormones causing cellular damage there's no
good evidence that this happens in humans
with sunscreens or that even if there are
small disruptions they are anywhere near dangerous
I'm assuming they wrote this based on those FDA
blood absorption studies but again the safety
has been assessed in a lot of other countries
chemical sunscreens including octisalate are
potentially dangerous toxic harsh cheap but
their product is made with wholesome ingredients
also this bit there is no evidence that zinc oxide
harms coral zinc oxide is worse for corals than a
lot of chemical sunscreens and this isn't just
nano zinc oxide this is any zinc oxide because
the thing that is hurting the coral is zinc ions
this doesn't seem to be a big issue except for
maybe outliers where there are a whole bunch
of people swimming near the coral with tons of
sunscreen on the concentrations measured at
reefs is much lower than what's required to
really damage coral and this is the case with
any sunscreen including chemical sunscreens
including oxybenzone and octinoxate it's really
just these outlier measurements that seem to be
a problem there are issues with this data
which I will talk about in a later video
and if all this wasn't enough they
also have tridecyl salicylate in
their products as well which is like
the third triplet with his hair parted
the other way and of course the ewg
also rates this safer than octisalate
tizo so tizo says they are free from
chemical sunscreen filters except the
ones that aren't actually approved I guess
they also have this FDA thing but at least
they say 12 chemical ingredients they
have this fun comparison table where
they show how minerals provide superior
skin benefits and most of these are just
not true I've debunked a whole bunch of
these before I'll do a quick speed run
version because because most of the brands
I'll be showing repeat a lot of these myths
mineral sunscreens absorb about 90%
of incoming UV and converted to heat
just like with chemical sunscreens the
total amount of heat is insignificant
anyway it heats up your skin
less than one degree celsius
a tiny amount of chemical sunscreen
absorbs into blood but it doesn't
mean it's harmful we have very sensitive detection
methods plus newer chemical sunscreens are
purposely designed to not absorb into skin
some people actually find mineral sunscreens
more irritating because they're gritty and
drying a lot of sunscreens from outside the US
that are for sensitive skin use chemical filters
allergies are only a problem for
people who are allergic to those
things I am personally allergic to tuna and
eggplant if you are not I do not expect you
to stop eating them in solidarity or
anything because they are delicious
chemical sunscreens don't all burn eyes and
some people find mineral sunscreens worse
zinc oxide is actually worse for coral
than a lot of chemical sunscreens in
that it causes harm at lower concentrations
and it's not a big issue anyway because the
concentration measured at reefs
have been much lower than what's
needed to damage coral apart from a
few outliers like I mentioned before
and of course all of these supposed cons apply to
butyloctyl salicylate as well which they are using
so again they are promoting this
misinformation about chemical
sunscreens while relying on an unregulated
chemical sunscreen to make their product work
Cotz stands for contains only
titanium and zinc [buzzer noise]
they also say they contain no
chemical sunscreens [buzzer noise]
and they just repeat a whole bunch of
misinformation about chemical sunscreens being
bad that is pretty much the same as tizo I wonder
if one of them actually got lazy and copied off
the other even the brand names sound kind of the
same and they're both founded by plastic surgeons
okay so I went off and researched this and
they have the same parent company and I
think they sued coola for copying this
particular formula with the butyloctyl
salicylate and in the legal document
they are just repeating all of this
misinformation in there does this
count as perjury I am not a lawyer
ghost democracy they turned the tizo table into
a bunch of essays and they added stuff about how
chemical sunscreens directly lead to skin cancers
inflammation and irritation which is - what?
apparently chemical sunscreens including
octisalate which is the twin brother of
their ingredient in their sunscreen they set
up an environment in which your skin absorbs
UV rays and transform them into heat and the
result of this is inflammation irritation
increases your chance of skin reactions
but they also increase your chances of
exposing yourself to other illnesses
including skin cancer in extreme cases
so they've blown up the less than one
degree of heat into skin cancer somehow
I don't know do these people like not
eat hot food not wash their hands in
hot water not take hot showers
like they only take ice showers
look if I sound mad I am mad because these
brands are making products less safe with
this BS marketing and they're probably
encouraging people to expose themselves
to a lot more UV which is a known carcinogen
by making them use a sunscreen that doesn't
work as well for no good reason and
scaring them about other sunscreens
I read so many reviews while researching this
video where people were just trying to make
mineral sunscreens work for them because
this marketing had made them feel like
they needed to use these mineral sunscreens
which of course these brands are selling
people are massively underapplying to avoid
white cast and mixing it with stuff I even
came across a brand that uses butyloctyl
salicylate of course and they're actually
telling people to apply pea-sized amounts to
their hands rub their hands together and pat
it into their body a pea is about half a
mil you are meant to apply a shot glass 30
mL to your body no one is applying 60 peas and
rubbing their hands together and patting it in
I don't think I'm even exaggerating when I say
clean beauty is literally killing people there
was this survey done in 2017 in Australia and
they found that only 55% of adults agreed that
sunscreen could be used safely on a daily
basis and this is down from 61% in 2013 and
2014 17% of adults agreed that ingredients in
sunscreen are bad for health if used regularly
and if you look up when clean beauty started
2017 is quite early on in the clean beauty
wave and this was well before tiktok became
this super powered flood of misinformation
and it isn't like it's fine because people
can just use mineral sunscreens instead as
we can see from these reviews a lot of people
are going to all these lengths to try to use
it they're putting I don't know 60 peas and
rubbing them together and patting them in
a whole bunch of people are not going to
bother with the 60 peas and they're going
to realise mineral sunscreens aren't worth
the bother chemical sunscreens and hybrid
sunscreens that have chemical and mineral
are worse for you than the sun and giving
you skin cancer anyway so people are just
going to go into the sun without sunscreen
and this survey is done in Australia which
has one of the highest rates of skin cancer
in the world more than 2000 people die
from skin cancer every year here pretty
much everyone in Australia knows someone who
has had part of their face cut out because
of skin cancer and even with all of this people
are getting increasingly scared to use sunscreen
and then on top of that they these brands are
also destroying trust in the scientific and
medical institutions who are promoting chemical
sunscreens and other life-saving things so it
isn't even just skin cancer which is already bad
enough it's other cancers infectious diseases
all of that stuff it's winding back all of this
painstaking slow progress that's been made towards
having longer and healthier lives and there's
limited funding for health and so governments
and scientists have to waste all this time and
money on things that we have already solved
and that means that we have less money for the
things that still need research so yeah I am mad
all right back to light entertainment
Babo Botanicals chemical sunscreens
apparently interfere with the
skin barrier what a pity because your
sunscreen has a chemical sunscreen in it
chemical sunscreens are apparently chemicals
cooked up in a lab including octisalate again
your chemical sunscreen's twin brother
they tell you to pay attention to the
active ingredients but apparently do
not look at the inactive ingredients
chemical sunscreens come at a cost
for both you and the environment
that is kind of vaguely threatening they
conveniently list out a bunch of chemical
sunscreens including octisalate
they say if you notice one of these
chemicals like octisalate listed in the
ingredients list it's best to keep looking
they whip out the word nasty and then they
literally link two of their sunscreens that
contain butyloctyl salicylate again I don't
think chemical sunscreens are nasty but if
you're going to call them nasty maybe don't put
an even nastier ingredient in your sunscreen
C'est moi this is an ewg affiliated brand they
were part of their clean con last year I did not
make that name up that is what they called
it they are kind of telling on themselves
they're ewg verified they adhere to European
cosmetic regulations as their baseline
would be nice if they also adhered to those
fair and honest marketing guidelines as well
they tell you to avoid chemical sunscreen
and look for mineral sunscreens like ours
of course they do just buy our
products avoid everyone else's
okay they have an explanation in their Sun
School series and it's this diagram that
we see all the time with that like bouncy
sunshine thing and yeah all of this is just
wrong and also kind of weirdly worded so they say
chemical sunscreens absorb skin damaging UV rays
good I guess they also absorb potentially
harmful chemicals which isn't that good
again let me remind you they essentially
use chemical sunscreens in their products
so it's pretty irresponsible
for them to be using something
that they say is harming humans and the
environment according to them at least
goddess garden you know it's going
to be good with a name like that
their sunscreens are a safe alternative to
chemical sunscreens they they say we are very
particular about the ingredients we select for
our formulas apparently not particular enough
to look up their actual ingredients apparently
we have the standard myths about how natural is
better ignore the fact that nature is constantly
trying to kill us and ignore the fact that your
product that you are trying to sell the
sole purpose of it is to prevent nature
from killing you like if nature was really that
safe then your products should not have to exist
biodegradable interestingly chemical sunscreen
actives are actually biodegradable but minerals
are not zinc oxide doesn't break down it
stays zinc oxide which generally isn't
a problem but if they are going to make a
claim like this it should at least be true
alright this bit is kind of hilarious
don't higher SPFs usually use chemical sunscreens?
often higher SPFs use chemicals to block UV rays
because higher mineral content can mean
a more whitening effect but we only use
minerals in our SPF 50 sunscreens and
we've worked hard to make them sheer
no this is exactly what you're
doing but in a less safe way
chemical sunscreens can also be found
in the bloodstream following use so the
FDA is conducting research to ensure
chemical sunscreens are safe for use
guess which ingredient they aren't
studying and octisalate is one of
the ones that absorbs into blood so your
butyloctyl salicylate probably does too
you will never find chemical actives
like oxybenzone and octinoxate in our
sunscreens because our families deserve better and
our environment does too I don't know
if using an unregulated and unstudied
version of a chemical sunscreen is any
better maybe that is what you deserve
all good this brand has gone above and beyond
with their creative marketing they've invented
something called the awful eight because
I guess actual alliteration is for chumps
anyway they're just chemical sunscreens
and they're saying other companies are
greenwashing for having chemical sunscreens
in their products while saying they're very
friendly because they don't have oxybenzone
and octinoxate which were the ones that Hawaii
banned and I guess the greenwashing
is kind of true but also they are
greenwashing because a lot of the chemical
sunscreens they've named are actually less
toxic for coral than zinc oxide especially
since you have to use a lot more zinc oxide in
a product to get the same SPF plus on top of that
of course they are using octisalate's outlaw twin
honestly they are actually really
creative they say octisalate is like
the X-Men of chemical sunscreen
ingredients it enhances skin's
permeability and that link actually
goes back to the colorescience page
apparently octisalate can negatively
impact your immune system and trigger
allergies and that link goes straight
back to the ewg because of course and
then there's this whole thing which
is what really really pisses me off
there's almost no point in wearing
sunscreen when the ingredients are
just as harmful as the sun you
wear sunscreen to protect your
skin so why poison it with chemicals I've
done enough ranting in this video already
bioclarity I swear this is the last one
I just wanted to mention them because
they have the standard stuff like break
up with chemical sunscreens apparently
chemical sunscreens are just too dramatic but
they also keep referencing the ewg which is
hilarious because the ewg actually
rated their sunscreens as very bad
like it's a seven it's in like that red
zone where you're meant to I don't know
burn it and make sure your descendants do
not go near it because I don't know it it
should just be like yeeted into space so yeah
stop citing the ewg they don't even like you
what are you doing this is sad
thank you for participating in my therapy session
butyloctyl salicylate isn't the only SPF
booster like this it is the most commonly
used one though and it is probably quite
safe but it does potentially open the door
for maybe less safe ingredients to be used in
a similar way most of these are boosters that
actually absorb UV are quite similar to other
sunscreen filters but unlike with butyloctyl
salicylate and octisalate some of these have
different enough changes to their structures
that you would expect them to interact quite
differently from the proper approved versions
and some of the properly approved versions do
have some potential environmental and health
risks that are being scrutinized so these are
kind of slipping under the radar so I really do
think these unregulated versions should really
go through the proper safety evaluation process
and with this very slow FDA approval process
for newer filters since 1978 there's only been
I think three sunscreen ingredients that have
been approved in the US and the whole chemical
sunscreen FDA safety reassessment on top
of all this clean beauty fearmongering
I expect these sorts of ingredients
will probably be used more and more
so I guess the takeaway here is apart
from the fact that clean beauty is BS
if you thought you were using a mineral
sunscreen and it turns out that some of
these ingredients are in it maybe you've
just learned something about your skin and
how you can't really generalise chemical sunscreen
ingredients they are a really diverse group and if
you're sensitive to a few of them it doesn't mean
all of them aren't going to work with your skin
so maybe it's worth trying out
some hybrid or chemical sunscreens
thank you for letting me get angry with you
today if you want more ranting there there is
a playlist here if you want less ranting
maybe try one of the science playlists